[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Todd blackl he played the
position won a national title at Penn
State former NFL quarterback and he will
be their NBC Big 10 Saturday night South
Bend it'll be Katherine taen Noah Eagle
Todd will be in the booth with them and
the festivities start tomorrow night at
7:30 Eastern on NBC and peacock Todd let
me start there with what Andy Staples
was saying the challenge of coming into
the NFL where quarterbacks have
receivers open as opposed to a
quarterback who has to throw his
receivers
open yeah that's a pretty interesting
point I mean you still have to have
basic mechanics and fundamentals to be
an accurate thrower you know even if you
don't have to fit in all Tight Windows
and you have guys getting open they
still have to put the ball in the right
spots I think in the case of a brock pie
he also you know he didn't necessarily
have the ability to to run extend plays
do all that kind of things the way
adjustin Fields does and so he had to
make sure that he was good with his
timing good with his accuracy good with
his anticipation just to you know to be
good period uh as a college quarterback
and certainly that's translated well for
him in the NFL too so what's Justin
Fields
issue you know I haven't watched enough
to to know I mean obvious ly it it
seemed like he and and the offensive
staff need to be on the same page you
know they need to understand okay these
are the things I do well let's let's
build around that these are the things I
don't like uh and and they just need to
get on the same page and make sure that
they are calling plays that he can be
successful at and that he feels
confident and comfortable in and um so I
you know I think it's a combination I
think it's him maybe you know locking in
a little bit more and and becoming more
more accurate and More in tune to what
it takes to be a high level quarterback
and then I think the coaching staff and
the play calling need to work in
conjunction with him in a in a higher
way how much of an advantage is Sam
Hartman's
age I think it's a huge Advantage I mean
in fact just watching him on the
practice field um and just you know his
presence it reminds me of the presence
Stetson Bennett had with Georgia the
last two years an older guy now Sam had
way more playing EXP experience than
ston Bennett you know but it's just that
maturity that that you know you're in a
locker room with a lot of 18 19 20 year
old kids and here's a guy who's played
50 games at at the division one level
the power five level and so uh he's got
the beard I mean he looks older you know
and he acts older and I think I think
that's a calming presence on that
football team how good is Marvin
Harrison he's as good as I've seen I
mean you know and I've seen some great
Alabama wide receivers some outstanding
players at Ohio State before him uh I
don't know that I've seen anybody any
better than than Marvin I mean he is the
complete package I mean he's big he's
extremely fast he runs great routes he
has excellent hands um and and I just
think the ceiling for him is is still
out there I think when he gets to the
next level you know he'll be an even
better player but is there a comparison
we always like comps is he a Larry
Fitzgerald or is he a Randy Moss or I I
yeah I would say probably closer to
Randy Moss uh you know in my in my
opinion because of the speed you know
and uh because he does have that
outstanding speed that you know the long
speed and top on top of you know the
quickness and the route running which I
think the route running a lot of the
nuances of being a wide receiver um he
got from his dad you know and was taught
because Marvin senior was an outstanding
receiver and Route Runner Hall of Famer
but but Marvin Jr is a bigger body and
typically it's harder for bigger body
guys to be intricate route Runners and
so that to me is one of the things that
makes him very special Todd blackid will
be on the call NBC it'll be big 10
Saturday night it'll be Ohio State at
Notre Dame and uh that'll be starting at
7:30 Eastern on NBC in peacock how
sustainable is what Dion's doing at
Colorado well you know at this point I'd
hate to to bet against him you know or
say that he can't do anything because
it's amazing what he's done so far um
you know the only thing I don't know and
because I've not covered one of his
games so I don't know the quality of
depth that he has on his roster and
that's the thing you worry about you
know as a season goes on and you start
playing conference games you get some
guys dinged up um what's your depth like
on your offense and defensive lines in
particular that that's the the biggest
question I have um you know they're
already without Travis Hunter who was
electrifying uh they're going to be
without him for you know potentially for
a game or two but uh so but in terms of
how well coached they are and the level
that they execute at um I think I I
think they can compete with anybody
right now and I think shador Sanders is
in a conference full of great
quarterbacks uh you know what the the
conference formerly known as the Pack 12
I mean uh he fits right in that
mold uh nil or transfer portal having a
bigger impact on college
football I I think I think the nil uh I
think both for sure uh but I think the
nil because at least with the transfer
portal it's like everybody's playing
with the same deck of cards and with the
nil it's it's kind of all over the place
you know and and um some places are
doing more with it some are doing less
some are allowed to do more some are
allowed to do less and so I think
there's there's more inequities you know
right now because there's no real
oversight on it from a national
perspective um so I think it's having a
bigger impact right now than than the
portal but from the the the standpoint
of redoing a roster and and reshaping a
team uh you can get a lot done with the
portal and instead of having to wait on
high school kids to develop uh you can
go find guys that have you know the
resume on tape of playing at that level
and plug and play a lot easier we have
these Old School coaches like uh dbos
Sweeney he doesn't believe in you know
nil uh you know the anti- transfer uh
portal you know at some point you you
know I don't I don't know can you
survive without embracing uh nil and
transfer
portal no and and you know I know dbo
has not wanted to really do a lot with
the transfer portal I do know they have
nil stuff going on at Clemson uh because
I you know done a couple games and I and
I know some of the things that they're
doing um but no I think you have to
embrace all those things um because
we're not going back to anything
different we're not going back to the
way it was the transfer portal was here
uh you know they they will tweak it in
terms of how many windows there are and
how long those windows are where kids
can jump in and out of the portal uh but
we're not going away from that and nil
is not going anywhere either in fact
it'll probably just continue to grow but
could you imagine Joe pno Woody Hayes Bo
Shen Beckler embracing
nil no I yeah
it's it would probably be uh enough to
drive them out of the game you know I
don't think that they would would want
to be in the game uh with with the kind
of stuff that that coaches have to deal
with now because you know managing a
roster is nothing like it used to be
used to those Old School coaches they'd
recruit a kid red shirt most of their
freshmen have them for five years you
know and build roster that way those
days are Way Way Gone great to talk to
you as always have fun on Saturday night
thank you Todd thanks Dan take care Todd
blackl he'll be on the call with Noah
Eagle Katherine Tappen it'll be Notre
Dame in Ohio State Saturday 7:30 Eastern
on NBC and peacock